my name is your boy richard rocko and
I'm playing myself in the movie line
like how did you find out about the role
the star of the movie
Paul Vandervoort he he was he liked my
music I had a big record called we're an
hour late he was a fan of the song and
he wanted to use my music in his film
and also he heard that I I had I did a
movie prior to this and he wanted to
give me a role in the movie as well
thanks to my agent and her sex he made
it happen and know it came together and
it worked out perfectly I started doing
music when I was really young I was
about 18 years old back in in my
hometown of San Francisco in the Bay
Area
probably about 10 years ago I put out
about 1718 mixtapes and two albums I've
been unsigned hyping the source magazine
double XL magazine and you know I just
know I've been one of the hottest on the
west coast for a long time ten years
I've been doing music and I've only done
one film prior to this movie limelight
I've done another movie called up behind
the trophy cuz that was my first film
but I did that about a year and a half
ago so I say about a year and a half a
year and a half to maybe two years at
the most I started my acting career and
what made you want to transition or just
add that to what you do in terms of
acting because you've done music for so
long and I understand musics in your
family as well right yeah a few of my
cousins are also very talented rap
artists and producers as well you know
but I wanted to get into acting too
because I didn't want to just limit
myself to music I felt like I couldn't
do anything I could play sports act you
know I'm saying do music I can do
anything
and I always respected to
artists like Ice Cube that were great
actors and you know went on to do well
in music
Tyrese I mean went on to do well and on
film Tyrese Ice Cube you know Ludacris
like I always respected people that that
didn't just stay within the music they
you know expanded their horizons and you
know went into other ventures and I felt
like I can do that as well so everybody
seems to think that I'm a natural so is
you know it's gave me the confidence to
keep going I'm not done
who was your biggest supporter in life
or maybe they're still here I have so
much support I have a big family and a
lot I have a lot of support from but
probably my two biggest supporters are
my cousin Bailey he also raps - but he
was the one who named me gave me the
confidence when I was young - you know
keep going and music and become Who I am
right now and my cousin Stevie Johnson
he's a he plays in the NFL and very
successful and he you know he's my
biggest supporter as well like we we all
got each other's back and now we support
each other but those two our price they
pushed me and give me give me my biggest
support and I understand in this film
limelight that you talk about
crowdfunding with the real character
what are your thoughts on crowdfunding
either film or albums to be honest I
really don't know what it is okay I was
just part of my life okay alright okay I
would love to learn more about it -
mm-hmm
okay one thing you don't know about me
I'm very truthful Dozo
oh that's great I was gonna make some
[ __ ] up but no please this dude's a
beast right here I thought he was gonna
make me bleed in this movie when you
first started in music how are you
making your songs cuz I know right now
that everybody can do stuff at home and
were you still doing it was it that
during that time that you could still do
it off
computer forgive me I'm not I don't know
much about making music I was going to a
lot of different studios when you know
my cousins they pretty much laid the
blueprint down for me shout out to my
cousin a SAN queen and my cousin Bailey
they were already wrapping it had their
feet wet in the game already so they
pretty much already laid the blueprint
down for me so I was when I was younger
I would just watch them and watch how
they did things and then put my own spin
on it or you know go go you know put my
own twist on things but I would go to a
lot of different studios and and work
and you know perfecting my craft and get
better and better and help you know I
have my own studio in my house I pretty
much learn how to wear a lot of
different hats in this music industry so
it's pretty easy for me like nowadays
like I just I just go in and it might
take me a week to make a song or it
might take me I were to make a song but
it just all depends on what type of mood
on my state on me
what is your music about what are most
of your raps about like most of my music
is about you know the it varies from
from the reality of how I grew up in the
streets
what was going on around me in the
streets or to my lifestyle now in
Hollywood and you know just it varies it
goes from you know it goes from from the
struggle to the luxury no think back to
when you were younger did you ever
envision your life would be as it is now
yeah and the crazy part about it is when
I was younger I envisioned my life being
even better than it is now so I know I'm
not doing it I know that uh everything I
look at in the world from if I look at a
Lamborghini to a big business like
McDonald's or anything that I look at
with my eyes I know that that came from
somebody's mind so I know that you know
my mind is very powerful so I always
knew that I would be someone great in
life and you know I'm not doing you I'm
still working hard every day
if you could send this video to someone
who's maybe 10 or 15 or whatever that
that maybe doesn't believe that this
could be possible for them
what would you say like I would tell
them that it is possible anything that
you want to do in life period is
possible like whatever you want to be
whether you want to be a star a movie
star a rap star R&B star whatever you
want to be a doctor a lawyer you can do
it you know I'm saying it's all in your
mind you just got to make it happen and
don't let nobody tell you you can't so
when you decided that you wanted to act
when was that few years ago or did you
probably yeah when I was young I wanted
to do it all I wanted to be everything
when I was young you know so I wanted to
be a big movie star I wanted to be a big
rap star a big football player I wanted
to do it all when I was young so I mean
I just I just applied myself as of
recently and put my mind to it and
decided this is what I wanted to do and
I'm making it happen right now
do you think at some point you want to
take another step where you become a
filmmaker not so not just a rapper not
just an actor but also a filmmaker yeah
one day you do one day I would like to
be a filmmaker I have a lot of great
ideas I'm gonna do fashion I'm gonna do
a lot of things I'm not done
what's a quote that has always stayed
with you that you kind of live your life
by I would say I love this quote by Jimi
Hendrix he said I don't like compliments
because they distract me and I kind of I
feel the same way it keeps me humble you
know that quote keeps me real humble and
when people up because I'm always
getting compliments a lot I love them
but I mean I don't like them at the same
time because I don't know it's just it
just keeps me humble
that quote keeps me from getting a big
head when people tell me how good I am
what is it about a compliment I've heard
another I think it was somebody else who
said
I don't trust people especially when
they're being nice to me
I thought that was an interesting quote
but what is it about that that you
gravitate toward just because I've seen
so many people change you know with
their success and you know when they
start doing good things and getting
praised I've seen them change and I
never wanted to be like those people I
always wanted to be that my same humble
good self you know and I felt like these
people changed because so many people
were praising them and giving them
compliments some people can't take the
blame or the attention you know I'm
saying so but me I'm different I get
complements and stuff all the time and I
remain that stay humble I take pictures
with all my friends you know I'm I'm the
same person I'm grateful for everything
that I have do you have any other
upcoming acting projects yeah I can't
really discuss the names of them but I
definitely have some upcoming film
projects you know my my movie agent
Aaron sax is doing a great job and you
know look forward to seeing me a lot
more on the big screen who were some
actors that you admire um some actors I
admire Will Smith Will Smith is a bit
dim he you know he did music and and he
did and he's a great actor a legend
so Will Smith George Clooney is a great
actor
Denzel Washington of course I really I
really have a newfound respect for
acting I thought it was easier than they
look you know saying I mean I thought it
was I thought it was easier than it is
it looked easy to me but once I started
doing it I seen how hard it is you got
to really get into character you got to
really make those people on the other
side of the screen believe and
I really I really have found a new
respect for acting and you know
everybody tells me that I'm a natural
but I know I can be better and I'm
continuing to get better I'm gonna be
great one day when you see a performer
that you admire going back to the
compliments this is a very interesting
quote do you give them compliments
knowing the way you feel about it yeah I
still I still give people compliments
because everyone is not the same
some people might need compliments to
keep them going you know so I try to
give credit where it's due so if I see
someone doing a good job I tell them
like you know you did a good job and
I'll even give constructive criticism to
like if they're doing the bad so I'll
tell them what them what they need to
change or you know I but I definitely
give give compliments and give credit
where it's due
so we'll get you up in the morning got
god gets me up in the morning and money
was that always the case for you those
two things yeah always that's always
been the case ever since I can remember
what you've achieved with music you know
starting at 18 and you're here now you
have this fan base you know you've
you've made videos you've reached all
these people do you think you want to do
the same with acting yeah I do
everything I own everything that I put
my time and mind so I want to put a
hundred percent into it and I'm and I
know when you do that you've seen big
results anything you know practice makes
perfect anything you put your time and
energy into you're gonna see results out
of this so I plan on putting a lot of
time and the same amount of passion and
heart into the acting as I do into my
music I'm gonna give it a hundred
percent every time do you ever take a
break or are you going seven days a week
I used to take breaks but now I feel
like I don't I feel like I feel like
I'm not taking no breaks as lately I'm
just all work I'm sleepy now but I know
things got to get done and I know I know
I'm gonna see rewards from me too so I'm
not really worried about sleep right now
or you know breaks I take breaks when
got my own island somewhere and my mom
got her own island next to mine you know